حيث اقتحمت قوات الاحتلال الاسرائيليه
بلده اليامون غرب جنين وحاصرت منزلا في
الملبح وادلعت الشبكات مع مقاومين
الفلسطينيين ما اجبر جنود الاحتلال على
الانسحاب من المكان وشنت قوته الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي الليله الماضيه وفجر اليوم
حمله دهم وتفتيش في مناطق مختلفه بالضفه
الغربيه تخللتها مواجهات في منطقتين نابلس
وجنين
كما هدمت قوات الاحتلال الاسرائيليه فجر
اليوم مدرسه التحدي 5 الاساسيه في قريه
جوبا زيب شرقيه مدينه بيت لحم بالضفه
الغربيه وفضل حسن بريجيه مدير هيئه الشؤون
مقاومه الجدار والاستيطان في بيت لحم بان
محكمه الاحتلال قررت قبل اسبوعين هدم
القريه بناء على طلب من منظمه تيريجافيم
الصهيونيه بسبب اعاقتها مخططاتهم
الاستيطانيه في المنطقه
وفي داخل الخط الاخضر عما اليوم الاضراب
الشامل قريه صندل في مرج ابن عامر احتجاجا
على مقتل الشاب ديار العمري البالغ من
العمر 19 عاما كان الشاب العمري قد استشهد
مساء السبت متاثرا باصابته بطلق الناريه
من مستوطن اسرائيلي اسرع عراق النشب
بينهما وفي سياق المتصل مددت محكمه الصلح
في الناصره اعتقال المستوطن دنس بوكين
قاتل الشاب ديار العمري لسبعه ايام على
ذمه التحقيق في الجريمه بينما اعتقلت
الشرطه شابين من عائله الشهيد بزعم عرقله
سير جلسه المحكمه